foreign
Bloomington
where the flowers bloom and just talk to
Melanie what's up Melanie how are we
doing
hi Dr John how are you
I'm good how are you I'm the literally
couldn't be better I'm doing pretty good
that's not true find some gummy candies
so what's up what's up
oh I'm calling because
I
struggle with seeing my dad's marriage
as something good
and I want to find a way to have peace
with being second to my step family
tell me more about that
so my parents divorced when I was 11
years old okay because my dad had an
affair
and he married his mistress as soon as
the divorce was Final okay
um I'm 36 years old right now
and I'm still
I still see that every time
I'm with them
I just never
so um for 27 years and I'm going to give
you
27 years wouldn't be fair because you
were 11.
um so you're 36 so let's just say 25.
for 11 years
you've deliberately chosen misery
either yeah we've chosen misery you've
chosen to hang out with him in a
violation of your own boundaries
wondering the whole time this 11 year
old little girl daddy why are you
picking her over us why are you picking
her over us
and you've continued that conversation
or misery you willfully want to go you
want him to continue to be your dad you
want him to continue to be in your life
and you have to be with
also with a woman who you have pegged as
the person who helped ruin your life
like why have you why have you chosen
this Loop for 11 years
um
I saw how it affected my mom
and
she has passed away
um she passed away in 2016. oh man
um and she was just a wonderful person
um
and it's just just like what you just
said it's hard to see
that he chose
another family
um over us
and I've done okay with it for a long
while like I have not dwelled on it this
entire time
like it was actually doing okay
um
what has started up is the last year
I've been spending more time with them
like trying because
you know I love my dad I want him in my
life and I want to be in his life I mean
because he's not a bad person
here's the big question does he want you
in his life
I believe he does okay
do you want him in your life because you
actually love him and care about him and
and you've forgiven him and you want to
have a new kind of you want to build a
new relationship with him or do you want
him because your mom has passed away and
he's all you got left or do you want him
because you are still desperately
hanging on to a fantasy that at some
point this all works out
laughs I feel like it's a combination of
all of that all of it yeah
clear all of the decks okay let's just
clear everything let's just take our arm
and swipe it across the table now we got
a clean table
instead of wading through all the junk
on this one
let's go to the very very end
you're 36 fast forward to your 40th
birthday
what do you want that to look like
when it comes to you and your dad
paint me a very very Vivid picture
I would like us to be closer nope that's
that's two that's two or more like paint
me who do you want at the kitchen who
you wanted at the dining room table do
you want your dad to swoop you up and
take you somewhere like what do you want
your 40th birthday to look like
I would love it if he called me up and
but hey I would like to spend time with
you on your birthday
this is your 40th and
I love you and
I want to spend time with you today
just us and
just
spend time together okay I'm doing what
it doesn't even have to be anything big
um we can go to dinner and talk we can
be at his house
and as long as she's not there right
well it's not like I I hate
them
I don't hate the woman
I mean kinda you do but
um so I went okay I want to go one layer
deeper tell me you're sitting at dinner
with him
how do you feel
like right now where you are put your
hand on your chest how do you feel
you're sitting at a table with your dad
I want more
no no no that's not what I'm asking fast
forward fast forward to your 40th
birthday
oh okay the waiter he you just saw it
caught your dad sneaking around telling
the waiter that it's her birthday and
they're gonna do some obnoxious
sing-along thing and he sits back down
and he smiles at you and he says
man so glad to be doing this with you
how do you feel in that moment
I would feel very happy well I that's
happiest happy cocaine and cotton candy
that's not real how do you feel
loved
uh
and you exhaled after you said love
you feel loved finally
yes okay
that's that 11 year old girl saying why
did you pick her over me
yes
okay
and my promise to you is if all of this
played out just from right now just in
not just the current state of your
relationship and you ended up having
that moment it would be mixed with
um
what you just like this piece this I
feel loved my dad showed up for my 40th
birthday and what you can't feel now is
my guess would be it would also be
filled with
rage
like you've wasted 29 or 30 years ago
like that right and so it would be this
weird cocktail that feels like it would
feel good right now so let me ask you a
hard question
would you be able to
invite your dad out
and have written him a letter and read
him the letter
part of that letter would say
inside of me is an 11 year old little
girl still wondering why you chose that
family over me
why you chose that family over me and
Mom and if you've got other siblings you
can name them
and then the other part of that letter
is
Daddy I have a dream that for my 40th
birthday you'll just invite me out and
we'll get to spend the day together like
we never got to do
I want to get to know you well enough so
that when that happens I'm really
excited about it
and here's here's why I'm suggesting you
do something like this
or let me ask you like you the idea that
you would do that how do you feel about
that
I I feel okay with that because I've
been holding it in for this whole time
we've never had that conversation so I
do want to so I want to validate you
this should be the conversation your dad
has with you because he's your dad
yes and it's been 29 years and it hasn't
happened yet so you as an adult are
faced with a choice
am I gonna walk away
um or am I gonna keep wishing
and I expect him to read my mind
or even worse am I going to live in the
ambiguity
and what you're doing is a gift to
yourself you're just calling it
you've been playing poker long enough
and he might be bluffing I don't
dad do you love me
and when you ask it when you sit down
and read him this letter he may stop
halfway through and say whoa whoa I'm
out of here
I left this when you were 11.
and I'm not here for it anymore I mean
I'm not here for it now he could walk
out and what you would get is
devastating grief and you'd get some
clarity
you could you'd be able to stop chasing
that that that that dragon
the other side of it is
you could
have 30 more years of relationship with
him
but you would have to decide to forgive
him
and stop carrying that baggage
yes
yeah
it feels like that baggage is protecting
you and it's not
it's weighing you down
or to say it another way
your hatred for him for what he did to
your mom combined with your love for him
as an 11 year old little girl still
chasing for chasing him chasing him
chasing his Blessing chasing his
Blessing chasing his Blessing that
combination there that's just you
drinking poison
and unfortunately for him he can't read
your mind
and you're expecting him to be a mind
reader just call me just call me and he
should he should call his daughter and
yeah he just has it
yeah
and he probably can't give you a good
reason if you sat down and said why
didn't you call he probably couldn't
tell you other than maybe he said I was
I knew you'd be so disappointed I didn't
want to bother you
because he might think he's a burden who
knows I don't get inside his head I
don't know why he's doing he's doing but
the end of the day
what comes next is on you
he has proven he's not going to do that
and if you told me dude I'm out of his
life I'm making peace with this I'm
going to write the letter I'm not gonna
send it I'm going to be done
I'm going to let him know how much he
hurt me I'm going to let him know all
the great things that have happened
since he walked out on me
and I am going to let him know the
things that I'm doing in my life and the
things that are to the are to come
he didn't get to be a part of that
basically you'd be grieving him just
like you grieved your mom
he's gone yeah
or you can choose to seek reconciliation
knowing that that's going to leave you
open to be heard again
foreign yes but also leave you very open
for some clarity
so what do you think what are you gonna
do
I think I would like to
write the letter and
read it to him I do want to give
that a chance
okay y'all live in the same town
um
mostly uh he was living out of state but
he's recently
moved back
I think it was back more than he used to
gotcha so that's how I've been able to
spend more time with him
gotcha
I
I can't tell you what to do in this
situation
I would also recommend that you take his
relationship with your mom
off of your plate
because there will be Dynamics to that
relationship that you will never fully
understand because you weren't in it it
wasn't your relationship all you got to
do is see it from
um from one side and experience it as a
child
so moving forward things are about his
relationship with you
and the ways he's hurt you the way he's
potentially blessed you
both of those things are true
um
and what you two decide
what comes next is going to look like
and I would even include that language
in your letter
none of us can change what happened in
the past the only thing we can change is
what happens next
and ask him are you in
and then be prepared this is the hard to
be prepared to tell him what in means
this means you take me to breakfast once
a week dad or once a month dad
this means we go to movies because you
should have taken me to movies when we
were kids and you never took me so now
you're playing catch-up do you have kids
of your own
no I don't okay are you married
no
[Laughter]
that was an awesome laugh
um
if that time comes you invite him into
that too right all I have to say is this
what do you want that to look like but
I can tell you if it was me I would
probably err on I I would do what you're
doing
um Life's too short for me to carry
somebody else's bricks not gonna do it
um Life's too short for me to drink
poison hoping that somebody else dies
Life's too short for me expecting people
in my life to be mind readers I've just
started being very clear and sometimes
that clearness comes across as like that
guy's a jerk or that guy's demanding
that's fine but everybody's on the same
page and that is an infinitely healthier
place to be
hang on the line I'm gonna send you a
copy of own your past change your future
I want you to read that as you are
writing this letter
read them do those things together read
the book and write that letter together
because the book's going to give you
some insight into your own stories that
you've picked up along the way and
you've been telling yourself for a long
time about the role you played and your
dad leaving which is nonsense
and then it's going to give you some
tools on that one terrifying scary
question
whoo what do we do next
what do we do next thanks for sharing us
uh sharing your life with us Melanie
appreciate it let us know how that
conversation goes give us a call back
because I want to know uh
hopefully he grabs Your Hands Across
that table and says hey honey I am all
in